إن فيروس كورونا هو كارثة أمريكية ،
لكن الرئيس بالأمس
يعرب عن
تفاؤله ، دعونا نذهب إلى
مراسلة طبية كبيرة إليزابيث كوهين
وإليزابيث للأشخاص الذين فاتتهم ،
أخبرنا بما قاله الرئيس عن
الجدول الزمني للقاح
، قال الرئيس إنه يمكننا الحصول على
لقاح في وقت أقرب بكثير.
أكثر من أي شخص آخر ، دعونا نستمع
إلى
كلماته بالضبط بالأمس ،
فنحن نقرب المنحنى
حيث يتم تسليم اللقاحات حرفيًا ،
وسيبدأ الأسبوع المقبل والأسبوع الذي يليه
وسيصيب عمال الخطوط الأمامية
وكبار السن
والأطباء الممرضات كثيرًا  من الأشخاص ،
لذا نبدأ توزيع اللقاح في
الأسبوع المقبل أو الأسبوع بعد
الآن ، فلنلقِ نظرة على الواقع ، لذا
دعونا نلقي نظرة على التقويم
الذي ستعقده إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) لعقد اجتماع مع
مستشاريها
في العاشر من كانون الأول (ديسمبر) حول لقاح شركة فايزر
، وهو أول لقاح
خارج البوابة  وقد قال رئيس
وكالة اللقاحات في إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير أو القسم داخل
الوكالة أنهم سيحتاجون بعد ذلك
إلى
المراجعة وإجراء التحليلات  لأيام
أو حتى أسابيع حتى لا يدفعنا ذلك إلى
توزيع اللقاح في الأسبوع المقبل
أو الأسبوع الذي يليه سيستغرق
وقتًا أطول مما يقول ما قاله الدكتور أنتوني
فوسي في نيه
لبعض الوقت الآن هل يتوقع
الأول  الأمريكيون الذين سيحصلون على التطعيم
في الجزء الأخير من شهر كانون الأول (ديسمبر)
وبروك كما ناقشنا ،
سيبدأون مع
العاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية في الخطوط الأمامية
وكبار السن وغيرهم من المجموعات المعرضة للخطر ،
ماذا عن لقاح أسترازينيكا على وجه التحديد
وأنا أعلم أن منظمة الصحة العالمية تثقل كاهلها
هذا اللقاح وبعض
المشكلات التي تم الإبلاغ عنها ، ما الذي يقولونه
حقًا ، هناك بعض المشكلات المتعلقة
ببيانات astrazeneca وبعض المشكلات
المتعلقة بشفافيتها ، لذا دعونا
نعطي نوعًا ما قائمة بالثلاثة الكبيرة ،
كان هناك خطأ في الجرعات
قدموه  ألف
شخص بالجرعة الخاطئة ، وهذا يعني أنه
عندما تبدأ في النظر
إلى تلك البيانات ، فإن نوعًا ما تفعله
بهذه البيانات وأيضًا ما هي الأخطاء الأخرى التي
قد تكون  تم ارتكابها لأنه خطأ فادح
في إعطاء آلاف الأشخاص جرعة خاطئة ،
كما أن هناك بعض البيانات المفقودة في
هذا البيان الصحفي والتي تم نشرها
قالوا إنها كانت
فعالة بنسبة 70٪ في المتوسط لكنهم لم يذكروا كي
توصلوا إلى هذا الرقم Moder
a و  عندما أصدروا
بياناتهم الصحفية ، فعلوا
ذلك من الواضح أن من يريد أن يرى
بيانات حقيقية وليس مجرد بيان
صحفي ، ولم يقدم أسترازينيكا في البيان الصحفي
أي تفاصيل
حول اثنين من المشاركين الذين كانوا في
التجارب السريرية
حصلوا على اللقاح و
طوروا مشكلات عصبية ، ولم يقولوا ما حدث
لهم ،
لماذا هو السبب وراء تأكد أسترازينيكا من أن
اللقاح لم يكن سببًا لذلك ،
فلماذا يجب أن يكون المنظمون على يقين من سبب
وجوب أن تكون إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير متأكدة جدًا من
سبب وجوب أن يكون هذا الشخص قصيرًا جدًا.
من سيطرح بالتأكيد أسئلة
حول ذلك أيضًا